hello everyone, i'm james murphy and as you can
see i am on python.org with some huge news. python
4.0 has just been released. let's take a look.
pep401 outlined some of the major changes coming
in python 4, and here are the big ones: we have
new old print syntax, mandatory static typing,
and stack overflow integration. i've
already taken a quick look at these
but i'm just going to go through sort
of the abstract reasoning and sort of
give you my impressions as we read through
it. so let's just read through it together.
okay so it's going to tell us about
the new features coming in python 4.
the 4.0 series is reserved for groundbreaking
changes in the python language and this is
nothing less than that. okay good. ever since
the original breaking changes made in the 2.7-3.0
transition the community has been primarily split
down version lines, agree, surveys have found
the average python programmer spends over fifty
percent of their work time converting two to three
with over ninety percent of that time um putting
parentheses around print statement arguments,
definitely. in python 4, the old print syntax
is going to be reintroduced so that you don't
have to change that old code anymore. it will
just start working again. that's awesome,
and of course the newer print function is going
to still be supported. next we have a fundamental
change to the type system. uh python was initially
developed as a dynamic type system, but it was too
flexible to allow offline optimizations by
optimizing the compilers. in python 4 type
annotations will become mandatory on all function
arguments, return types, and variables that cannot
be statically deduced. the standard library will
be typed completely with the exception of the
explicit "Duck" type and so most code depending
solely on standard library functions and types
will not need much change. this is a huge change,
it's completely overhauling the type system. type
annotations are now mandatory, but what do we get
for this? an average speed increase of over 30
000 percent and memory usage decrease of 50
percent across the entire standard library. again,
huge change, huge benefit. finally, python has
long been known for how easy it is to develop,
and yada yada yada, we're partnering with stack
overflow to bring automated stack overflow report
yields uh, in short, any time an unhandled
exception reaches the interpreter, the source
code, accessible state of the stack and heap, all
variables and values in scope will automatically
be uploaded and published to stack overflow along
with the relevant stack trace as a question to a
dedicated python overflow section of the site for
other users to debug. that means when you have
an error you don't even have to post it on stack
overflow anymore. it's already covered. and like
i said before, this was just accepted last night,
apparently it was a unanimous vote by the python
language committee and it's coming soon to a
python near you. this just all happened so fast. i
mean, there are so many new features coming, huge
changes coming, um i'm not even sure exactly what
to say. i mean, it all sounds really really good
so i just wanted to give you my take, uh, my first
impression on these changes. it's probably going
to be like a year before, you know, the release
actually happens um, but i'm always looking ahead,
always looking forward to that next release. so
let me know what you think of these changes down
in the comments. don't forget to like, comment,
and subscribe, i'll see you next april fools!
... yes obviously this is an april fool's joke.
there is no python 4, yet, and none of these
things are ever going to be implemented in python.